going back to Cincinnati this week how's
it going to feel returning to that
Stadium I think it's going to be super
electric and I think it's going to be
nothing but love only thing I got to
compare to is just going back into our
stadium and how much love and and
reception it is you know so going back
into there I'm pretty sure it'll be like
a a bunch of you know memories which
will you know make it emotional for me
but I ain't running from it I'm I'm
ready to walk through the fire I think
it's going to be all love I think it's
going to be all energy all support I'm
super excited to see it I remember just
watching on TV from hospital just seeing
the stadium um when we played the
Patriots right after everything happened
and it was like electric like I think
it'll be on that same level in same
atmosphere so you know I'm I'm super
excited I'm thankful man I'm blessed and
I'm I'm just appreciative on both ends
of the support from everybody in
Cincinnati the team the fans everyone
showed my family love while they were
there for you know a whole week like you
told me man one thing that Just Let Me
ease my mind man you already won yeah
literally like the hard part's already
over